(upbeat music)
- Welcome back to another
episode of the AddyHour.
As always, it's my pleasure to be here
with all of you as listeners,
and have continued to really be encouraged
by all of the feedback that
you all have been sending in.
So today I'm really excited to continue
on our theme on so many different levels.
This is really a pinnacle in a sense,
'cause we're gonna integrate
across many of the different things
that we're really passionate
about here on the AddyHour.
And today I'm honored
to be able to welcome Dr.
Stephanie Pinder-Amaker
for conversation about diversity, equity,
inclusion, and mental health
on campuses and in society.
So obviously that's a
very encompassing title,
but I think, as you all will hear,
this is very appropriate
for the work that she does.
So just to give her a brief
introduction, Dr. Pinder-Amaker
is McLean Hospital's Inaugural
Chief Diversity Equity
and Inclusion Officer.
She's the Founding Director
of McLean's College Mental Health Program.
She's an Assistant Professor of Psychology
in Harvard Medical School,
and she's a Consulting Psychologist
for the Boston Celtics.
So, many different roles as you can hear.
And we will also touch on the whole aspect
of balancing and juggling in
this conversation as well,
partially selfishly, because
I get that question a lot too,
and it's always helpfully
hear others talk through
that aspect of their journey.
But in terms of, again,
the intro introduction
to Dr. Pinder-Amaker, she
is someone who is guided
by the models of cultural humility
and shared responsibility,
and she's passionate
about moving organizations
beyond diversity by the numbers
towards sustainable,
inclusivity, and promoting
culturally responsive
mental health approaches.
She's consulted for dozens of universities
and secondary schools, also
sport teams and nonprofits
to really develop interventions
at the intersection
of social/cultural
identity and mental health.
Her new book, "Did That Just Happen?!
Beyond Diversity,
Creating Inclusive and
Sustainable Organizations,"
has been selected as a
community reads choice
by colleges and corporations,
and has also been nominated
for several national awards.
And that's a book we'll be
talking about today as well.
Along with her co-author
Dr. Lauren Wadsworth,
she actually serves, of course,
on several advisory boards as well
to several different organizations
that committed to social
justice and health equity.
I should also mention that we share
a couple of different alma maters as well.
Dr. Pinder-Amaker graduated
from Duke University with her BS,
then went on to do a
doctorate in psychology
from Vanderbilt University,
and then did pre-doctoral
and post-doctoral fellowships
at the Yale School of Medicine
and at Duke Medical School respectively.
So someone that I have some
mutual background with,
so to speak, and it's
my pleasure and honor
to be able to welcome her
here to the podcast today.
- Thank you so much.
It is my pleasure and my
honor to be here with you
at the AddyHour.
- Wonderful.
- And just wanna say,
to be healthy and whole,
one must approach things holistically.
I love that.
- Yep. Yep.
- Thank you for that.
- Of course, you're in the right place,
I mean, obviously that's in our essence,
but even just hearing you speak
that is so just encouraging,
as I can tell that it
resonates with you as well.
So definitely looking
forward to being able
to have this conversation.
And I've really appreciate the ways
that we've been able to connect
over the past couple of years,
even before we start this
podcast and just the insights
that I've been able to
gleam from your work.
And so in some ways this
is full circle for me
to be able to introduce you
to our listeners as well.
So appreciate you being here.
- Thank you, thank you.
- And of course, as you know,
and as my listeners know,
I always just like to
start with a check-in,
especially with everything that
we're continuing to navigate
as a society.
And some ways it feels like,
because things are so
heavy and challenging,
it's almost surreal in a sense
that just talking to different people,
it seems like some people are
really weighed down by it,
some people are trying not to
pay attention to it as much
because it's too much,
some people are kind of
in between those two.
So I would just be curious to hear,
especially in the work that you do,
how you've just been navigating
through life on a daily
basis at this point
as you tried to balance
what you do with your work
and then just navigating everything
that so many of us are
experiencing in society?
- Such a good question.
Thank you for checking in on that.
Doing pretty well right now.
Certainly better I think now
than this time a year ago
and better than the year
before that at this time.
So I feel like trending
in the right direction
and that's important.
As you mentioned, it's been
an extremely demanding time
to be in both the fields of
mental health service delivery,
as well as promoting
diversity, equity, inclusion,
and belonging sort of across the board.
So I feel like I've learned
a lot in the past few years
and really had to put into
practice new strategies
for maintaining balance
to keep it all going
in the right direction.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- So a work in progress.
- Yeah, yeah, I think
that's a helpful answer
in so many ways,
to even know that someone
like you in your position
who is practicing it for others
and trying to instill those
and still working through
that yourself too.
Would you be willing to share
what some of those new practices have been
for you, personally?
- Yeah, sure.
One, interestingly enough,
we started a new practice
with our staff meetings.
Before we jump into the agenda,
we actually have a check in,
like a personal check in,
and I can't take credit for that.
It was like another staff member
who said this would be really important
for us to do right now.
And so that's been helpful.
A few things that I practiced
that became really important to me
during the height of the initial
surge of the pandemic was,
I guess to say it plainly,
to begin practicing what I preach.
As a mental health provider,
I do so much speaking
and talking and teaching about self-care,
but really had to push
myself to put those practices
into place and maintain them for myself
and to hold myself accountable for that.
One of the practices that I started doing,
I do a lot of talking and speaking about,
resilience, for example.
And so I created for
teaching it, this pneumonic
for remembering some of the
evidence based components
that promote resiliency.
So I'm still working on,
this is hard to say verbally,
but the way that I see it in my mind is,
I think about a title resilience
and then the number six/S.
So resilience 6/s.
But the six S's, that's how
I remember the components.
And what I do for myself is
do like a scan of those areas
to think about how I'm
doing across those areas.
And if I'm feeling sort
of unmoored or off balance
or out of sorts, then I do that
scan across those six areas
to see where I might
be letting myself down.
And it's something that I've been,
like I said, practicing
and teaching for years,
but had to really begin
implementing it for myself.
Do you wanna know what the six S's are?
- Yeah, I'm very curious.
(both laughs)
- So, structure,
which I don't typically
have a challenge with that,
but a lot of people did have a challenge
with maintaining structure
during the pandemic.
So, structure, self-care, which is huge,
and spirituality, those
are the first three Ss.
And then the last three
are sense of purpose,
sense of belonging, and sense of humor.
So I'll sort of do a
personal scan of those areas
to sort of figure out what
needs some bolstering.
And it's been really helpful.
And the other strategy I'm
happy to share is so basic.
It is just taking a walk,
but a specific kind of walk.
I've read about it in the New York Times.
They called it an "awe walk."
I was doing it before
I saw the title of it.
And all it is, is getting
outdoors and just taking a walk
and trying to discover something
that you've never seen before.
Just something you could be in awe of.
And so pretty basic,
but it's been helping.
- That's great.
I mean, basic but powerful
in so many ways, too.
And I mean, so many things
of what you mentioned really resonated,
just practicing what you preached.
I can think of so many instances
where I verbalized some of
those things in certain settings
and then had people respond and say,
oh, that really resonated
with me when I heard you talk
about just having to
reset your expectations
and know that you might be in a place
just because of everything that
was happening with pandemic
or, otherwise, that you might not be able
to hit those goals,
and to be able to say "that's
fine and take a step back."
So just to hear that you've
been verbalizing some
of those things as well.
And then as you mentioned
maintaining, that's huge.
'Cause talking to so many
people who had good intentions
but weren't able to maintain that,
but then were able to do that
through connecting with other people
or having people hold them accountable.
So I think that's amazing.
And it's funny, because as
you mentioned the walking,
I even was thinking back,
I shared this with people
in my research group to do,
the beginning of the pandemic,
just being more specific
about taking some daily walks
or few times a week and working out more
and somehow that just
kind of slipped away.
So that maintenance part
definitely wasn't there,
but to be able to even verbalize
that and have people say,
okay, I also feel like I couldn't keep up,
and that helps them kind of move along,
but so many aspects of what you share
I think are so powerful,
simple and powerful.
So I know that people listening,
even hearing those six S's
will be able to put some
of those things in place.
- Yeah, and I feel like the six S's,
resilient 6s really aligns very nicely
with to remain healthy
and whole one must approach holistically.
And so it kind of think
about the whole sort
of realm of your life.
Because it can't, at least for me,
it can't be just one
intervention or one strategy.
I really need to think holistically.
This past weekend, for example,
I went to an outdoor concert,
an outdoor jazz concert,
first concert I'd been
to in over three years,
and it just really fed my soul.
It was wonderful to be back
in community with people,
but also outdoors.
- Yeah, that's true.
And I imagine you probably felt the music
in a different way, too.
- I really did, I really did.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- That's so good.
Well, I know that people are listening
are gonna be encouraged
even by that already.
And then you mentioned holistically,
I mean, as you were
sharing those six steps,
I was thinking there's a
lot of discipline there,
but there's also aspects of hope
and thinking about
ourselves as whole beings
as you talked about the spiritual side,
as you talked about humor.
So you out to be able to have those things
that really pick us up
and just give us life.
So I'm impressed already.
And I also appreciate the honesty
about saying that it's a work in progress.
So I know it's not perfected by any means.
- Yes, it's definitely a work in progress.
And I think that in the
early stages of the pandemic,
I mean, to be like fully transparent
at moving to working remotely,
what happened to me is what
happened to so many people,
is that my Workday really extended.
Without the commute on both ends,
I just jumped in earlier
and I was being so efficient
and getting so much done
and feeling really great about myself.
And then about maybe 6,
7, 8 months into that,
really had to stop and
observe what was happening
and how I had really lost some
degree of work/life balance.
And it's just really important
to take note of that,
to recognize when it's,
or at least to have someone check you.
In my case, I did have someone.
And that was my spouse,
my husband, who said,
"maybe we're gonna stop
bringing the laptop to bed."
(both laughs)
And at that moment, we both said,
"let's talk about what we've been doing
and figure out how to reign this in
and how to help support
each other in that regard."
- That's so good.
Yeah, to have someone who's
willing to call you out,
but then also to walk it out
with you at the same time.
- Call you out, walk it out.
I like that.
- Yeah. That's great.
- I'm gonna use that.
- Yeah. Feel free.
(both laugh)
- I'll credit you.
I'll credit you.
- Either way is fine.
Now that you brought it to my attention,
I'm gonna use it as well.
(both laugh)
It works for both of us.
- Good. Good.
- But, I mean, that's really
encouraging to hear it too.
On that same note,
'cause, I mean, now that we're
gonna use this call it out,
work it out or moniker
we just came up with.
I'm curious, within the
College Mental Health Program
that you've been leading,
one, if you could talk
a little bit about that
and then also talk about
what you've had to do within
that realm within the pandemic,
because all these things
that you've mentioned
that many of us have been struggling with,
and especially if there's
mental illness involved,
I'm curious how that has
also impacted the work
that you're doing,
but maybe just to start
to give listeners a sense
of what that program looks like.
- Sure, sure.
So the College Mental Health Program
is somewhat of a unique model
because we're a hospital-based
College Mental Health Program,
which, in itself, is a little atypical.
Usually these programs are based
within institutions of higher education.
But the reason that we
decided to develop the program
is that although we work
in a hospital setting,
so not situated directly
on the college campus,
each year in our hospital system,
we see college students from
over 200 different institutions
of higher education annually.
And that's just an
extraordinary statistic.
I mean, it still blows my
mind when I think about it,
but I think it's helpful
to sort of start with that
because it really is that statistic
that drives the work that we do,
because it is such a
unique sort of demographic.
And so we focus on three areas.
We deliver student-focused care,
strategies that really focus
on the student identity
and integrate those strategies
into existing treatment models.
And so we work with students
at all levels of care,
and for your listeners, what
that means specifically is,
wherever students might seek
mental health treatment,
whether it's at the
inpatient level of care,
which is the highest level of care,
or in a day treatment setting,
where someone comes consecutively
for a period of weeks each day
to do a little intensive outpatient work,
residential, students in
residential treatment,
who are in treatment and
living on the premises,
and then outpatient.
So we see students
across all those levels of care,
presenting with the whole
range of psychiatric diagnoses.
But we specifically
integrate a student focus
into that work.
And because we see such a
broad number of students,
a large number of students
from such a broad number of
colleges and universities,
not only do we deliver
clinical treatment work
and do a lot of,
basically just trying to
help folks think about
how to support the mental health needs
of students more effectively
by taking into
consideration the fact that,
this sounds so obvious,
but that they are students.
And so why does that matter?
Why is that so pivotal?
Which typically does not always happen.
So there's a clinical piece,
and then we do research.
That's another sort of
domain that we work in it.
And the easiest way to describe that is,
as we're developing new
strategies and interventions,
things that we think are improving
the mental health outcomes
for the students with whom we're working,
we're also evaluating that
because we don't wanna just guess at it
or say we think this is
working or we suspect this.
We wanna have the evidence
and document that evidence.
And we've been able to
do that over the years.
Be able to show that when you
integrate the sort of focus
on student identity into
traditional models of care,
like in our outpatient, excuse
me, our day treatment setting
that the students actually do
better in terms of their level
of reducing levels of
depression and anxiety
when that sort of focus has
been integrated into care.
So there's the treatment piece,
there's the research piece.
Is this working, is it not?
And if not, let's figure out what does.
And then a really big piece of the work,
which is constantly evolving,
centers on the fact that we see students
from all over the country,
and that piece is we engage
colleges and universities.
So we provide consultation
services to schools,
and, essentially, really
strengthening the relationship
between the work that we do
and the work that they're doing
and constantly putting our
heads together to figure out
what's working for the
students that we actually share
and what's not working and what's needed.
And so we develop new
strategies, new interventions,
new services in partnership,
and then collaborate, new
policies, new programming
with colleges and universities
all over the country.
And so that's the sort of the full span
of the work that we do.
So we're not,
our work isn't just situated
where the hospital is
in Belmont, Massachusetts.
We spend a lot of time visiting campuses
and engaging with students
and staff and faculty
and mental health providers
on college campuses as well.
- I mean, it sounds so
comprehensive and so important
on so many fronts,
the way that you're really
integrating across those pieces.
again, meet people where they are,
which we've talked a lot
about on this podcast,
but then also be informed
by whether the things
and the practices and
interventions are effective or not,
but then also partnering
with so many different entities as well.
I'm curious as you've done that,
'cause you even talked about policy.
How did you make inroads into that?
Because it sounds like
there's a level of trust
that has to also develop there,
one, to be able to listen
and try and work together,
and especially if that's
gonna move towards policy
on campuses.
So how has that piece come about for you
to actually be effective?
- Dr. Addy, you took the words out of,
are you reading my mind?
The most important thing
and the very first thing
that we had to do in
developing the program
was create a level of trust,
'cause you can't just make this stuff up.
And as you know,
you can't just show up on campuses
an an expert in anything, for that matter.
But you have to figure out
how to strengthen the relationship.
And so we went about that
in a very intentional way
from the outset, do a number of things,
an example, a number of processes,
one example is we created
this range of programming
that we titled "McLean Host"
and then fill in the blank.
And so we started reaching out to,
there are like 75 to 80 colleges
and universities just within a
close radius of the hospital.
So it's a good place to be able
to build a College Mental Health Program.
But we started reaching
out and inviting folks
from campus to visit our campus.
And that was one way of
strengthen the relationship,
getting them from there,
from where they sit on
their campus to where we,
and our hospital setting also looks
like a small college campus,
the way that it's situated.
It's not like in a physical building,
like a single structure, but
really spread out over land.
And we engage them and
ask them to think about,
when they came to visit us,
what they wanted to explore
about how we are working with students.
So taking them through an abbreviated tour
of some of the work that we were doing
and just kind of building,
getting to know each other basically.
And we had,
one would think of as like an
exchange program, if you will,
where then a reciprocal,
where we would visit the
College Mental Health Program,
CMHP for short, visits.
So, MIT, McLean Host MIT,
and then the CMHP,
CMHP visit MIT and so forth.
And so just in doing that,
like spending time in each
other's respective homes,
that helped to build the trust.
And we would ask schools also
when we'd learned the schools that we,
we didn't know before
we started the program
how many schools,
the large number of schools
that we were seeing.
So once we had that information,
we reached out to those folks and said,
"hey, do you know that
each year we're seeing
about 50 of your students in our setting,
and would you be willing to get together
and just talk about what's
working on your campus
to address the needs of those students?
And also, from your
perspective, how are we doing
in addressing the needs of your students?"
And just kind of opening
up, asking the question,
often hearing great feedback,
like, oh, we really love
working, but sometimes not.
This is what isn't working
when our students come.
And we've really worked hard
to elicit that honest feedback
and said, just tell us,
because this is all in
service of our students.
And so without that information,
we can't get better.
And we have information that
might be helpful for you
in providing more effective
support of your students
from a mental health perspective.
And so really just building the trust in,
that was just an example,
that programming,
but we have kind of
dozens of those strategies
for building the trust.
But I just love that
you asked specifically
about the term trust
because that's absolutely what's required.
And the main reason I know that is
because I've been an
administrator on a college campus,
and I know that colleges and universities
can be really concerned and guarded
about what they're sharing
and who they welcome in
to collaborate with them and so...
- Yeah, and did you use that?
- Just build the trust.
- In a sense, I mean,
did you mention the roles
that you had had before
as you're (indistinct)...
- Yes, yes.
- Or did you just have let that, okay.
- Actually did,
and, especially, whenever
visiting the campuses
because it, I think, just
lowers everyone's anxiety.
And you can see this in any discipline
if someone comes into your space
and they've actually worked
in your type of setting.
My job at the University of Michigan
had oversight of college
student mental health.
So when I'm engaging with
colleges and universities
and they hear that,
there's this almost like
an exhaling, like, okay,
you get it.
- She gets it.
We don't have to explain.
- Exactly.
- 'Cause there's so many misconceptions
about some of the challenges
that people are facing
regarding college student mental health.
And so there's that piece of it.
The other thing that I did
in my administrative role previously,
when I worked at the
University of Michigan
as Associate Dean, was also,
I had oversight of critical
incident management
and developing an approach and a structure
and a strategy for anticipating
and responding to crises on campus.
It's another element of
campus life and college life
that people don't speak about very easily
because a whole range of things can happen
that can be extremely challenging.
So I think those two things
combined really made,
and continue to make it
easy for us to engage
with campus professionals.
- Yeah, I think that's really powerful,
I mean, so much of the foundational work,
and you spent the time doing that too.
And I'm sure that that people sense that
and knows that that time
and investment is there.
And even as you were sharing just now not
to pivot too far off, but I'm curious,
as you talked about some
of the preventative things
in anticipating crises,
would you say that was a standard practice
or was that something
that was maybe more revolutionary sense?
Just because from my limited scope,
just seeing so many of our schools,
and we've done this ourselves as well,
they're reactive rather than proactive.
So hearing you talk
about that from earlier,
I'm curious if that was just something
that you all were doing
that was ahead of the game
in the sense or if you've
seen things change,
are people more in that space?
Because that seems like it has
so many important implications for crises
and also in terms of mental health as well
and mental health crises that can come up.
- That is a brilliant question
and, again, right at
the heart of the matter.
When I was recruited to
join the student life staff
at the University of Michigan,
what you just asked was
sort of the reason why,
and this was now 20 years ago.
And it was specifically
because this is often the case
on many college campuses, they had,
in their case, gone through a
particularly challenging year
with a number of crises, a
full range of campus crises.
And they had been doing
a really excellent job
of responding to,
but felt like they didn't
have an infrastructure
for anticipating
and also didn't have a strategic response,
the things that were very clear,
there were some phenomenal
people on the ground,
like the vice president of
student affairs, for example,
and deans.
And these are the people who
sort of had in their heads,
what to do when a bad thing happens.
And they were really, really good at it.
And they would show up themselves
to wherever and whatever,
any time of day or night.
And what they experienced
at that particular year
was that there was a
real spike in incidents
and a broad range of them.
And that they couldn't catch their breath,
that they felt like they were
constantly putting out fires,
this fire, onto the next
thing, onto the next thing.
And that there was no time to really stop
and think about really a
structure and a process.
They had certain values and principles.
The University of Michigan is a highly,
highly oriented towards social justice.
So an example would be that,
an approach to responding to crises
would always be, by definition,
multi-culturally informed.
That's just steeped into the fabric of
how the division of student life works
and things at the organization.
But how do you create that
so that people can come into
the system and understand
what that looks like and
document it and teach people.
And then create an
opportunity for the university
to be more proactive
in anticipating crises
so that we're out of that reactive mode,
and able, not always,
because there will always be emergencies,
but in some instances, you can
look six months down the road
and say, "oh, this controversial speaker
is coming to campus.
What are the things we can do now
to prepare our institution
to respond to what is going to be
a really challenging
situation more effectively?"
And you can do that for
a whole range of crises
that inevitably are going to happen
at one point or another.
So it really was about
creating an infrastructure
so people could get out
of that reactive mode
and feel more and be more
proactive in anticipating
and more thoughtful in responding to.
We had a whole range of,
anything could end up being
a crisis on a college campus.
One that sticks in my mind at the time
was the Asian tsunami that
happened at that time.
And you're talking about
a large university system
with a significant international
student population.
That tsunami happened
during semester break
so many of our students were not on campus
but in their respective
parts of the world.
So just think about that.
How do you respond in a way
that's gonna also be
multi-culturally responsive as well?
So I think that was all long
answer to your question,
but I... (laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, so powerful.
I mean, so informed by all
the different things...
- And from a mental, I'm sorry,
from a mental health perspective,
we designed new strategies
that now have become really
standards of best practice,
like creating a critical
incident response team,
or what many schools
refer to as a behavior,
there are all these
different names for it.
But specifically at the
intersection of critical incidents
and mental health,
a lot of the structures
that we take for granted now
on college campuses,
those kinds of teams
and that team approach,
we started those at the
University of Michigan.
- Wow, that's really encouraging to hear
and to know the foundation of it as well,
and the ways that you all
were so forward thinking.
I mean, even as you're sharing now,
still so many things that
we can learn from that.
So, again, just encouraged
and not surprised
to know that you had your hand then,
just the team there,
it seems like was really
intentional about that as well.
- Yeah.
- In lot of ways, it also
makes me think about the book
that you just published, I
guess, about a year ago as well,
because in some ways,
it seems like it has multiple components,
both the preventative piece,
but then also it's informed
by so many vignettes
and stories.
So not that it's a reaction to,
but in some ways it also
feels like a response
to things that have been
happening for quite a while,
even as you're trying to help
create these more diverse
and inclusive cultures and environments
without doing things
that will be temporary
or just tokenized or all
those other many other types
of words we could throw in there.
I was curious if you could
just share a little bit
about the impetus for writing
the book in the place.
- That's right, you just
picked up on something else.
It's so important for this work.
And it's something that I carry
with me in my work at McLean
in the College Mental Health Program
and in the Diversity
Equity Inclusion Office,
and specifically in
consulting the colleges
and universities, when we engage
in partnership with schools
or any organization to
sort of do the work,
address sort of a crisis
or a critical incident,
what we ask, and this I really learned
from having been in the critical incident,
what we ask is, in our contract,
let's figure out together
what's gonna be sustainable,
which is one of the themes of the book.
We're not gonna do a one and done.
One and done doesn't work.
So we won't partner with an organization.
We don't want to
perpetuate that tokenizing,
oh, we're throwing
resources at this thing,
we're focused on this issue,
this crisis for this semester.
And then guess what?
Next semester we're onto the next crisis.
We're not doing that.
And we know how that happens.
So let's figure out together
how, from the outset,
what we put in place can
be sustained over time.
And we'll work in partnership
to figure that out
because it serves no one,
least of all, your students
to bring this intervention one year
and have it disappear the next.
So, yeah, so really a
through line, if you will.
And your question about the book,
the impetus you asked
about for writing the book.
So many things.
As I think about for Dr.
Lauren Wadsworth and myself,
there were a couple of things.
One, we both have hold
minoritized identities
within academic and medical settings.
And we had our individual
and shared experiences
that sort of came together
while working at a
particular organization.
And we were being called upon
to serve as experts on
different areas that,
my expertise, for
example, within my system,
I was recruited there specifically
because of my expertise
in college student mental health
and critical incident management.
Now, it just so happens that,
I think that culturally
responsive treatment
should be integral to
all treatment approaches,
to all psychology programs,
but that's not always the case.
So Lauren and I had
some shared experiences
and sort of being
continuously sort of look to
as the expert in all things,
diversity, equity, inclusion related.
And at a certain point we had
developed so many workshops
and talks and we just decided together
why don't we just document
some of these things.
So put some of this in writing,
as well as some of these experiences.
And that was sort of one driving force.
So sort of to to be more efficient.
So we've said this thing so many times,
how about we commit it to paper?
We don't have to repeat it all again.
But there were couple of other
driving forces, and one was,
we were really obsessed with
this idea of inclusivity
and helping organizations to
think about how to move beyond
what I refer to as
diversity by the numbers
to actually thinking about
what does an inclusive
workplace look like,
what are those practices,
what are those behaviors and those skills
so that as we are so highly
focused and motivated,
especially in recent years,
to recruit diverse talent
into our organizations.
What can we do to ensure
that we are prepared to really receive
and welcome diverse talent
to ensure that folks,
when they show up in our organizations,
that people feel safe or relatively safe,
that they feel valued, that
they feel heard and seen?
So kind of really breaking it down
into what does the practice
of inclusivity look like.
So that piece of it, which
is kind of a lot of people,
I mean, some really great
thinkers in that space, of course.
And then the other piece
that really drove the
structure of the book was,
how do we make this plane?
We both happened to be
clinical psychologists.
We're also researchers and clinicians.
We wanted to bring what we knew
from the practice of psychology,
like evidence-based
strategies, to the work,
but lose the jargon.
So keep the science, but lose the jargon.
- That's an impressive skill.
That's so important.
(both laughs)
- It's so important, right?
And it's a lifelong skill.
I'm fascinated by that.
But we wanted to just make it plain
so that folks didn't have to
peel through layers and layers
of, I mean, the data are there
and the statistics and everything,
but really not have to
look up every other word
to figure out what the heck
are they talking about.
We wanted to make it plain so
that people could pick it up
and find the skills accessible
and like, oh, I could do that thing.
I could do that today.
And I don't have to be
an expert in X, Y, and Z
in order to do that and
to practice that skill.
So sort of those things
combined really shaped the book
and specifically, the structure
and the content of the book.
It's why we chose to begin with
vignettes real life stories
to make it plain,
so that people could just read
or hear a story and think,
"oh, my goodness, I've seen that before,
or I've experienced that,
or I've said that."
I can't tell you how much
feedback we've gotten
from folks saying "I've seen
myself in those vignettes
and not always on the receiving end
of identity related aggressions,
but sometimes as the perpetrator."
So connecting with the stories
and then that's why there's
the vignette opening,
and then the next part of the structure
is kind of like, what's
wrong with this picture?
Why is that programmatic?
So just making it really
plain, this is not okay.
Here's why.
If you don't already know, here's why.
Lots of people don't know.
And then what to do about it?
Which is a question that I think people
have been really sort of pressed to answer
in the past few years.
Yes, in this time of racial
reckoning and unrest,
what do we do?
What do we actually need to do?
And so really practical,
skills-based, evidence-driven,
but like I said, without the jargon.
- Yeah, that's really
powerful on so many levels.
And even that comment that you mentioned
about some of the feedback
that you're getting.
People even realizing
that they've maybe sometimes
perpetuate things unknowingly.
I mean, two things that stand out there.
One, the fact that people
were reading the book
in the first place,
which makes me think they were open to it,
but then also that may
have given them a chance
to see things in the way they
may not have caught before
and then to actually have
practical things they can do
to walk that out.
So, I mean, I think that's so impactful
in so many different ways.
And there's one of the
things I was curious about.
If people are actually seeing
best practices come out
of their reading of the book,
and it sounds like you're
definitely getting that feedback.
And I imagine that can have
so many ripple effects,
even as you talked about
the theme of the book,
trying to have these sustainable things
that really change cultures,
which is no small task by any means.
So just encouraging to
hear that type of feedback
that you've gotten already.
- Thank you.
We are both humbled and
encouraged by the feedback,
and we're learning more every day
just from how organizations
are utilizing the book,
responding to the book.
One of the things we had
hoped for in writing the book
was that the work could be
accessible across industries.
But we had no idea.
Again, hit the nail on
the head when you said,
well, I'm happy to hear that people are,
A, reading the book, 'cause
we certainly did know like,
is anyone gonna read this?
You don't know.
You just put this thing
out there in the world
and pray and hope that
someone will resonate with it.
So we are really encouraged
and humbled by the range of industries
that have been selecting the book
as their organization reed.
And we're seeing that in,
not surprisingly in academic settings
and in institutions of higher education.
I mean, that's kind of where we lived.
Not that we expected that.
We hoped that for that.
But it's being selected
by secondary schools
and that's really encouraging by finance,
in financial spaces, law firms,
the American Society
for Clinical Oncology.
We've been going on the book tour,
much of which has been virtual,
but more recently, now it's in person.
And so we are learning so much
because these types of organizations,
again, across industries,
theater, publishing,
are selecting the book
as their community reads
and then inviting us into
this space, research labs,
the Tsai Center at Yale was one.
But it's just such a different experience
to go into the space
where the entire workforce
has been working with the book
and then they have a range
of questions and issues
and responses.
It's been just so encouraging to see
how people are leaning into the work
and really eager to take
steps to learn the practices.
So you asked about best practices,
I feel like best practices
are emerging all of the time.
From our perspective,
through this process,
we're learning so much.
We have a consulting company
and we also have workshops
that are aligned with
the chapters in the book.
So sometimes, not always, but
organizations will invite us
to do a book signing and a book talk,
but then also to deliver
workshops and the top,
there are several, but the number,
well, the top two requests
are to learn how to do
what we write about in the book
as empowered versus oppressive listening.
So that's emerging as a best practice.
And then the other is, not
surprisingly, how to recognize,
respond to, and reduce the rate
of identity related aggressions,
which is the term that we use
to refer to microaggressions.
So, primarily, it
switches as time evolves,
but right now those are the areas
we are getting the most request
to come and help us think how to practice
and learn these skills.
- Yeah, that does sound so encouraging.
And I'm curious, for our listeners too,
especially those who might not have heard
the identity related aggressions as well,
can you elaborate a little bit on that
and why that term and not microaggressions
and where it has shifted
in terms of your thinking
and what you've seen from others as well?
- Yeah, and we're hearing lots about,
what people's language is
I think really important.
And so the term microaggressions,
there's been some,
that refers to sort of everyday slight,
often, unintentional...
sort of targeting some aspect
of an individual's
social/cultural identity.
So maybe race, ethnicity,
gender, sexual orientation,
age, the whole range,
but unintended everyday slights
that create harm over time.
And so that term that's commonly
known as microaggressions.
And there's been a discussion,
a lot of discourse over recent
years about the term micro,
which actually means
several different things
when you look at the
people who coin the term,
but some people were sort of pushing back
against the micro part,
feeling or believing that
it minimizes the damage.
And as we were writing the
book, we were thinking that,
when the term microaggression
was first introduced,
that it was probably necessary
to use a term like that
to help people understand the harm
and not feel so guilty about it
that they couldn't even delve into
why this is so problematic,
but we feel like we're
far enough in the field
that we wanted to respond
and eliminate the micro piece
and really focus instead on the impact,
centering the identities
of individuals frequently
with marginalized and
minoritized identities
who are on the receiving end
of these everyday slights
and insult.
And so we've took out the micro
and replaced it with
identity related aggressions
to do two things,
sort of remove that piece about,
make sure there's no misconception,
the impact of these
behaviors is significant.
It is major, it's really
hurtful and harmful to people.
So coin the term, I coined the term IRAs,
Identity Related Aggressions,
also sort of picking up
on the financial term,
helping people to remember that the impact
isn't in the individual insult,
but it is in the accumulation
of these everyday slights,
but it accumulates over
time and the physical
and the psychological impact
on people really takes a toll,
well documented toll scientifically,
and we really wanted to
highlight that aspect of it.
- Yeah, I think that's so helpful.
Yeah, and just really, as you mentioned,
things have shifted in time.
And just where we are, it
sounds very appropriate to me
and really just helps
center, as you mentioned too.
So I'm hopeful that you've
probably gotten this feedback
that's really helping people
grasp it in a different way,
and in a new way as well.
'Cause even hearing high
school students talk
about some of these things,
those conversations
have definitely come up
in terms of the aspects
with the word micro.
So, again, not surprised
that you're at the forefront
and thinking ahead for many of us
and helping us really frame these
in a really appropriate way.
So definitely appreciate that as well.
- I don't know that I'm at the forefront,
but just definitely on
the journey together.
It's just a shared journey.
So we're all learning from each other.
And we've been learning so much from...
I'm thinking, again,
about a best practice,
one best practice that's been
emerging that Lauren and I
are learning a lot through this year
of having been on the book
tour is how important it is
in organizations, companies, groups
to give people permission to name the ism,
refer to, call a thing a thing.
And because historically,
we're really taught not to say these words
and not to be able to talk about racism
and sexism and transphobia
and ageism and ableism,
really taught not to say those things.
We're more comfortable, at
this point, naming sexism
I think as a society,
but stuck almost to the point of paralysis
when it comes to naming racism.
And that, in itself,
I think is interesting
and helpful to think about.
But we're seeing how important it is
to give folks permission to name the ism
and also to practice,
practice, practice, practice.
You've gotta practice these skills.
So we really are very
intentional about creating spaces
and opportunities for folks
to hear themselves saying the words
and hear each other saying the words.
And it's just like, wow, I said that.
I said that thing just happened.
It's not okay.
It sounds like it really
comes from a place
of historical racism.
It's not okay, it's not who we want to be.
So let's figure out how we
address it moving forward.
- So I feel like that's been
an emerging best practice.
I can go on if you want here.
(Stephanie laughs)
- These are great.
These are great.
Well, my curiosity is also peeking as well
because we touched on at the
beginning of the episode,
just having you share a little
bit about just your own,
I used the word balance loosely, juggling,
because as I'm hearing all the impressive
and important work that you're doing,
I'm just curious how you have
that cadence for yourself,
as you even talked about
you and your partner
just making sure that
you have time to pause.
And how are you in that
aspect of the journey?
As much as you're willing to share.
And, again, this is
partially a selfish question
because I get that question about myself.
And I'm always thinking about
with the many different roles
and initiatives and
responsibilities I have.
So I will divulge that there
is some personal investment
in the question as well.
Curious about that regardlessly.
- So, full disclosure,
I mean, this idea of,
I talked about that I'm really obsessed
with this notion of...
sort of operationalizing
inclusivity and belonging,
but just as important is this
notion of sustainability.
And so, as we were talking about earlier,
putting forth an approach or
a practice, an intervention,
but ensuring that the
thing that you're doing,
whatever that is, can be
there for the long haul.
And that's been definitely a through line.
It's a question that I think about
since becoming diversity
equity inclusion officer.
It's really a guiding approach
for how we do the work.
In fact, even our core staff,
as we're thinking about a solution
or a response to something or new program,
we always routinely ask ourselves,
is this thing sustainable...
for ourselves and for the organization?
And if it's not, if we
can't introduce it today
and figure out how it's
gonna still be a thing
in six months in six years,
then we're not gonna do it
because this really requires
being in it for the long haul.
And so just that one practice certainly
has helped maintain my own
ability to stay in the work,
to continue to show up.
And another sort of principle,
it's not just kind of talking about it
and it's going from
teaching and talking about,
but also to figuring
out how to practice it.
But I love this idea of
shared responsibility
for doing the work,
and it truly has made it possible
for me to still be a
social justice activist.
So when I assumed the role
of the first diversity
equity inclusion officer
for McLean, what we
decided at the outset was,
we're gonna do this,
but we're gonna do it with a
model of shared responsibility.
And what that means is,
it's not gonna be my job
and it's not gonna be the job
of my, or the DEIO Office.
The work isn't gonna be marginalized.
It isn't going to be in parallel to.
That has to be integrated.
And that the whole organization,
every member of the organization,
needs to be challenged to
think about what their role is
in promoting diversity.
So really integrating it into.
And it sounds like such a basic thing,
like, yeah, of course,
shared responsibility.
We're all responsible,
but actually creating cultureship
so that people feel like, okay,
I want to own responsibility
for doing better.
But then how do I do it?
And creating a structure
and a system for doing that
has absolutely been a personal
and professional lifesaver.
Had I not done that, I'd have
burned out after year one.
And that's not to say, as
I mentioned at the outset,
it is a work in progress.
I am definitely a work in progress.
And in that first year,
I overextended myself
in dozens of ways.
And then another practice
for sustaining has been
creating self-care partners.
And sometimes, at the end of the week,
in certain groups at work,
we'll end the week with what
our commitment to self-care,
one self-care activity is
gonna be over the weekend.
And then we begin the
week by reporting back
- Wow, that's great.
- And what that thing is.
We also, I mentioned, we do checkouts.
One thing that we do
as part of our checkout
within our multicultural
psychology consultation team,
our check in, did I say checkout?
We check in.
(both laughs)
Where that came from but...
(indistinct talk)
I know, I know, let's not, let's not,
(both laughs)
When we check in, we will
also rate level of burnout,
and we do that routinely
on a scale of one to five,
with five being the highest level,
routinely, and it's just
been a really nice practice,
one, 'cause it's makes
us, me specifically,
pause and think, how am I doing?
And integrating that practice,
it's part of the agenda.
It's not something that's hit or miss.
We do it every single time we meet.
What's the level of burnout?
And then we ask, if the
level is three or higher,
is there something you need from the group
or the organization?
Sometimes there is.
Sometimes folks will say,
"yeah, I need problem solving
around this one thing,
or I need support on this."
And other times people will say,
"no, it just helped to be able to share
that my burnout level
is creeping up there."
Another practice that's
really helped sort of
to keep me whole and
showing up in the work
is one that we also instituted as part
of that multicultural
psychology consultation team.
And when we check in, we
report our level of burnout,
but we also report on...
upstander moments that we have
observed in the prior week,
both seized,
upstander moments where either you
or you witness someone else really lean in
and be effective as an
upstander in responding
to an identity related aggression.
And we also report on
missed opportunities.
And sometimes those missed opportunities
will be opportunities that, we ourselves.
Like, this happened and I
really missed the moment,
and I wanna name that.
And that's been surprisingly
very rejuvenating.
Often what happens in the group
is that people will get
acknowledged for upstander moments
that they didn't even
realize were so impactful.
And so it's really positively
reinforcing the work.
- Yeah, there's so many good
practical tips in there too.
And, again, I just love
the way that it's balanced
between the times when
things have gone well
and the times where there's
still room for growth
and then just even creating the space,
like with the check-ins,
to have an actionable item or
for people just to say that,
oh, that was just helpful
just sharing that.
I mean, that's so,
that's so encouraging, so
practical in so many ways.
I think this is one, again,
one of those episodes
that people are gonna have
to listen to more than once
to really catch all these great tips
and hopefully to be even able
to purchase a book to read it.
And it's really encouraging just to hear.
I mean, I know this is
a foundation of years,
that none of these things just popped up
at any specific point in time,
but you've really laid a foundation
with the different roles that you've had
with your career experiences,
with your life experiences.
And I'm just grateful for the ways
that you've shared that with our listeners
and the ways that you're sharing that
across so many different
realms, as you mentioned,
institutions and environments
and educational systems.
So just really encouraging
to hear what you're doing.
And I'm grateful that I've
been able to have you here
to share that with our listeners as well.
And as I mentioned at the onset,
I've been able to glean from it as well.
And this definitely impacted my thinking
and how we've even gone about things
on this AddyHour podcast.
So definitely appreciate you being here.
Any last words of, you've
shared so much already,
but any last words of wisdom or things
that you wanna leave our
listeners with in particular?
- Well, first of all,
thank you for having me.
I always love our conversations
and I was really looking forward.
And I just love what
you're doing in this space,
in addition to all of the other spaces
in which you are such an inspiration.
I guess, I would just
leave with the reminder
to remember to do your own
personal resilience 6/S scan
as a strategy to sort of identify
where you might need to do a
little bit of additional work
to sort of keep yourself in
the work for the long haul.
- That's great.
- I have to keep saying it.
Every time I say it, it helps me too.
Because then I remember,
"oh yeah, I'm supposed
to be practicing that."
- Yeah, I think that's great.
I mean, so honest too.
That helps all of us,
just to know that it's a practice
that even you have to continue
to remind yourself about.
And, again, I know this,
the people are taking so much
in just listening to this,
so definitely appreciate you being here
on the AddyHour podcast.
Definitely appreciate the work
that you're continuing to do
and appreciate the ways
that you've mentored me
in this journey as well.
So, Dr. Pinder-Amaker thank you, again,
for joining the AddyHour podcast
and for all that you're doing.
- Thank you, thank you, Dr. Addy.
Thank you for having me.
(upbeat music)